let's talk about the escalation of War
because we got this year's story from
the Daily Mail FBI director agrees with
energy Department report that kovid most
likely leaked from Wuhan lab and claims
China is thwarting and obfuscating U.S
investigations into the virus so uh okay
uh shout out to Colbert because he
actually pointed this out in his bit
although he was trying to be dismissive
he said the raise in the department of
energy is putting out a statement on the
lab lake is because they actually
oversee bio Labs so a lot of people are
you know Jon Stewart made a joke when
asked about he's like I wasn't waiting
for the Department of energy to weigh in
on this one they'll laugh and it's like
well they actually are the authority as
they oversee biolabs and uh the FBI
director uh Christopher Wright agrees
the lab leak how about this so what's
the debate now what's the argument can
we just tell all of these crackpot
liberal people in the corporate press
they were wrong and and they should be
fired or what
Fireball uh for other reasons I guess
we're reporting what they were told so I
don't know if you I don't know so is
that so so wait wait so you know I hire
a reporter and then I'm like go report
on what's going on the pandemic and then
after you do I'll tell you what to write
yeah basically that's how those
corporations work it's true but yeah I
mean those aren't journalists and they
should their their PR spokesman for
powerful institutions they're reporting
they're not investigating well like
everything it goes back to Trump because
Trump was the one who said this virus is
from China suggested that this was the
source of it and so the media and their
reflexive uh Behavior then of course had
to come out and say no
that that's not it
um and so they just dug their heels in
and there wasn't a lot of reporting on
this until
um you know not even this Revelation
there were others stepping forward do
you think it was Trump
he called it the China virus right away
I mean a lot a lot of people were
blaming China but Trump was a very loud
and prominent voice very early on
blaming China he was critical in China
early early in his he was always
critical of China
do you think that that was the
motivation behind the push against the
The Narrative that it was a a wuh
there's a really that it was manuscript
there's a really great video where
there's this Doctor Who says the reason
people didn't work the reason the Press
ignored the lab League stuff is because
we funded the lab and it was
embarrassing and if we didn't fund it it
would be 100 of Americans agreeing it
most likely came from the lab but it's
it's insane that uh I mean the video is
fantastic it's insane that the media
literally said this and I have people
repeating it to me I had a friend be
like no I think it probably came from
the wet market and I'm like you think
the bat coronavirus didn't come from the
bat coronavirus laboratory it came from
the wet Market a block away from the
laboratory where someone drove a bat
from a thousand miles away to eat
instead of the lab where they had the
actual viruses that I you know that's
how I that's how I feel too I don't I
think that Donald Trump would get
pushback no matter what but I think that
because the U.S government was funding
the lab in Wuhan and the covet virus
likely came from the lab in Wuhan that
that is going to make the narrative
pushback
doesn't mean we can call the China virus
now I mean I don't see a problem with it
but someone's going to say you're a
racist I'm part Asian so I'm allowed to
and you're racist if you tell me I can't
okay yeah I don't even know white
liberals coming to me and telling me
what my people are allowed to say that's
racist you know I'm I'm trying to have a
conversation over here yeah but uh
they'll they'll call Larry aldera white
supremacist so you know they'll just
they're gonna call you they're gonna
call it a racist no matter what I mean
it doesn't matter like it doesn't matter
what you say because they're they're
going to call you names and they're
going to frame it in in a way that can
slime you no matter what I I think dirty
smear Merchants as we've mentioned this
in the past couple of nights I think the
US is getting ready for war with China
and they need this narrative I don't
think so because they were working
together on bioweapons in Wuhan so I and
and no one we're like Neighbors in the
Pacific so I I don't think so I don't
think yeah with Russia with like Alaska
and Russia China and Russia all being
kind of like a very large area that
you're thinking of and we're not we're
not neighbors You could argue we're
neighbors everywhere in the world
because the hegemonic powers are
pressing against each other's borders
but like we're all neighbors it's like
yeah and shooting at each other but sure
neighbors like Pakistan and India our
neighborhood they've got Pacific Coast
access any any of these Pacific uh
countries I would consider like our West
Coast neighbors like sure but like
Australia China is our principal
adversary and they've been like sending
warships into our territorial like near
or just outside of our territorial
Waters Alaska and Hawaii I think they're
deathly afraid we're gonna invade China
you think China's scared the US will
invade gently afraid I think that makes
you say that really because they're like
a crumbling economy with just just using
us as their their greatest sales agents
if we cancel our alliance with China
they they go bankrupt that's one that's
different or trade lines that is
different to invading mainland and China
I think that's the fear of most people
around the world is that the United
States is going to invade no like that's
not China that's not even that is so
that is so outside of the the realm of
possibility there's there's I mean
actually maybe maybe that's why because
it's the least likely thing I figured it
out I figured it out here's what we got
to do America Americans got guns right
yes the U.S just needs to build like a
land bridge to China and then tell
Americans go yeah and because you know
here's what I was thinking the the
Chinese people have no guns and so if
you took every American citizen and just
plopped it right on top of China like
instantly the Americans would take over
and own the place because we got so many
guns if they have no guns what are we
going there for well because I was
thinking like they don't have oil we
wouldn't invade they have Rare Earth
mines Rare Earth minerals are actually
everywhere but just China's got the
industry but um if the US was going to
invade John I thought it was I was
thinking about this and I'm like yeah
why doesn't anybody invade the US well
it's obvious obviously because there's a
gun behind every blade of grass but not
in China they've got the the a big army
they have the largest ground uh standing
ground Army but that won't matter when
you have how many people are in their
army not 300 million let's say you take
a hundred million U.S adult men with
guns
you know it's a hell weather to the
country don't win any War like it's all
the men China is a very weak militarily
they have good technology but their
their citizens are like malnourished and
impotent they have a billion and a half
people fighting with backhoes and stuff
it doesn't matter
if they don't have weapons if they don't
have ballistics important side point
that people are bringing up Adrian Curry
just said avoid Discord they'll ban you
yeah we need to find something other
than Discord right there's another uh
there's something out there that's an
option I forget the name of the the
company that runs it yeah we'll figure
it out Matrix is one uh The Matrix
protocol like element element chat but
it's pretty it can be pretty buggy right
I mean rumble's working on something for
us so we'll see what they can cook up
yeah oh you think Rumble will make a
colon function or something yeah I think
they're literally building something for
us because we need something bespoke so
well if that's the case Rumble should
build Channel chats and then we can
embed the channel chat on all of the
content so there's always a chat room
available everywhere 24 7. hey that's a
good idea I like that yeah gilded is the
name of the other the other uh company
that I was thinking of gilded yeah they
do essentially the same thing as Discord
but I bring up this China stuff because
I think that as Americans we've been
like indoctrinated by to live in fear of
other people since uh 911 basically I've
seen it pretty intensely and I don't
think that anyone has any intention of
invading the United States right now to
be like poking the bear and and I mean
look at what we did with NATO how we
pushed it right up to the Russian border
and then blame them for for moving
forward like it's like putting turrets
right you were yeah putting a bunch of
turrets right outside someone's front
door yeah
I don't think any of it is serious
because these aren't serious people
including the people who are running our
military people who are in charge here
and everywhere else they're just not
serious they're not capable people are
you saying that you don't think anything
serious
look at this to do what beyond what he's
already doing
I love this meme I don't think he wants
to invade the US no he doesn't I I agree
with that or I don't think he wants to
invade Poland I don't think he wants to
invade anywhere this is a good example
of us thinking that the Iranians are a
threat Iranians are a threat to the
United States it's a meme where it says
Iran wants war look how close they put
their country to our military bases and
then it shows all of the US military
bases surrounding Iran yeah I don't
think that the United States is at any
threat to anyone but themselves at this
point well the U.S is a threat to a lot
of people around the world yeah well I
mean there is no threat to the United
States Beyond themselves at this point
if we implode and rip our country apart
that's the end of America otherwise
happening and you know what whatever
that's why I'm saying look the argument
for Trump the argument about Trump was
that if you revert to
nationalism and you reduce
internationalism secure the borders
bring manufacturing back it's it's
semi-isolationist I'm not saying you cut
yourself off from the world but what
happens then is the petrodollar crumbles
the U.S becomes reliant on its
manufacturing base to do tribute with
other countries instead of military
might and uh so my attitude was like
look if you like the way you live where
you don't you can write articles about
you know celebrity gossip and get paid
60k a year then you want to vote neolib
you want to vote neocon you want to vote
establishment because bombing kids in
Yemen sells weapons of Saudi Arabia
which props up our economy and then you
get to do nothing for everything but if
you vote for Donald Trump you're gonna
have to roll up your sleeves get a good
job take care of yourself figure things
out on your own and you're not going to
get this free ride from blowing up kids
Donald Trump's foreign policy I think
proves that and I've always been about
the U.S should not be using military
might for economic Advantage around the
world but I tell you this all these
leftists and all these liberals if you
actually place them in front of like a
fork in the road and you said the fork
on the left ends all war
from the United States and the Empire
but you'll have to work from sun up to
sun down on a farm to survive and the
road on the right we blow those kids up
but you get cheap cheeseburgers they
will all walk down the Right Fork every
single hipster College leftist will take
the go ahead and blow them off if it
means I don't gotta work because already
we're seeing these videos of young
people being like they're filming
themselves on Tick Tock going why do I
have to work to like live
adulting yeah yeah the word adulting
full term oh boy thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time